the last piece is important legislation
that was passed relative to the
environment which was the brownfields
revitalization act in 2001 2002 I guess
it actually got through unfortunately
Congress has not been able to come to
agreement on any other major piece of
environmental legislation and not that
we've needed to stop protecting our
environment but we just can't get the
political consensus that we've had and
then you look at the non row diesel rule
which is reducing the emissions from non
row diesel engines tractors and backhoes
by 95% and those are a bigger threat to
human health and the environment than
the diesel buses and trucks on the roads
you look at the watershed approach to
managing water pollution because
pollution nonpoint source pollution from
actions that all of us do in our
everyday lives are more important more
difficult now to deal with than the
point source pollution so there there
are host of things that have been done
and been done well and of course
preserving one of the largest areas of
the water off Hawaii is a major
accomplishment setting that aside and
all environmental groups would admit
that that's a very good very strong
statement and a very good position to
have taken
you